[Music]
it's summer 2020 and life's back to
normal or
almost normal for some of us after
practicing social distancing
staying at home and watching anime all
day anyway in today's video we're going
to be listing the most promising anime
shows of 2020 summer season for you to
add to that ever growing watch list of
yours
we'll be picking the names that we feel
are going to be a good watch so without
further ado
let's get started
my teen romantic comedy season three
since they're a grantee ad let's begin
with the sequels and move them right out
of the way first
so firstly we have the third season of
my teen romantic comedy
team yukino or team yui a dilemma that's
baffled the modern day anime viewer
regardless of which side you choose to
stand on in anime history
it's gonna be a very sad day if the
hachiman decides to choose none of the
bays and go
solo
[Music]
also coming back for a final round is
sword art online alicization war of
underworld part 2.
it's time for kirito and his girls to
kick some serious butts
left and right in an epic finale battle
if
of course our duel wielding simp ever
comes back to his normal senses
back at the high time of the fire season
the action and the explicit fan service
show
fire force is back with the second
season boys and girls so be prepared for
next level action sequences
smooth animations and light-hearted
funny inappropriate
scenes
god bless japan
the long-awaited re-zero second season's
here
the breaker of one-horned demon hearts
back only to face death
again and again and again and i wish him
to die a thousand deaths
after rejecting the best girl and making
everyone lose their mind with his
legendary quote
which i totally do not wish to say but i
will say anyway because you know moral
obligations
just say i love you back because she's
the goat
[ __ ] what i love amelia season 2 is
back
get ready for muhiyo and roji's bureau
of supernatural investigation
second season did you fall a victim of
the evil spirit possession
is there a beautiful ghost in your room
that wants to kick you out of your home
if the answer's yes then you need muhio
and roji
experts in magic law banishing evil
spirits is their speciality
after the somewhat success of the first
season muhio and roji's bureau of
supernatural investigation is getting a
sequel
this summer the show didn't gain any
serious attraction at the time
which makes me believe most of you
didn't watch it hence you have the
chance to watch the first season whilst
the second is airing
to finish the sequel entries we have no
guns life
2 with a huge morally grey and broody mc
with a giant revolver for a freaking
head
returning for a second season in dark
cyberpunk world
part of the reason i enjoyed the manga
and i'm currently enjoying the anime is
that no guns life has some full metal
alchemist vibes in it with regards to
the theme and plot like political
intrigue
dystopian elements and of course the hot
blonde mechanic
it is a refreshing show to watch so if
you have the time don't sleep on it
make sure you give it a chance
[Music]
now with the fresh new goods we start
this half with a bang
the god of high school it all began when
our main protagonists invited to join a
martial arts tournament hosted by shady
corporations
as a prize the winner gets his wish
fulfilled by the hosting corporations
no questions asked now i'm not going to
talk about it very much
not because it's bad because on the
contrary it's very good and well known
to all anime fans
whether it's new or old fans everyone's
heard of the name unless you were
literally
living under a rock anyway the long
wait's over and the anime adaptation of
the famous manoa is here
like tower of god you can find god of
high school on webtoon if you're one of
the fellows who likes to read fight
scenes
unlike tower of god though let's hope
god of high school will keep us
entertained
till the very end
now 95 percent of you aren't going to
know who yoshitaka armano
naoki serizava yuzo koshiro are
if you happen to be one of the five
percent then good for you you're a high
level of virgin
for the rest of you these folks are big
japanese names collaborating together to
give you the brand new anime show gb8
so if you want to see edo era time
traveling samurai and shinobi in
post-apocalyptic ruins kicking some
germs but
then look no further than this anime
show with its events set in 2030
because it's got you covered
for all the lonely weebs out there next
we have rent a girlfriend
if you can hire an escort to escort you
and play hide and seek before bedtime
then why can't you rent a girlfriend to
fill the void in your life
in short rmc a typical loser who got
dumped by his girlfriend
decides to use an online app to rent a
girlfriend but
things don't go as smoothly as he
expected so
if you feel emotionally burnt out then i
suggest you wait till the next episode
of rent a girlfriend
it may have the answers you seek which
will probably turn out to be
pretty useless in real life
the misfit of demon king academy is next
a catchy title check a generic character
design
check ladies and trailer check
mc getting reincarnated check
set of weak female characters who are
likely for for the all-round powerful mc
check well it seems we have another
anime with an overpowered mc to add on
the list
enjoy
[Music]
up next is decadence if you go to my
anime list to read the description
you're probably likely to say hmm
that's very unoriginal and if you watch
the trailer you might also say
hmm as well one more anime
with humanity at the brink of extinction
by the sudden emergence of the unknown
life forms
with the remnants of humanity now
dwelling in a 3 000 meter high mobile
fortress
with a hope to win a war that's an
attack on titan knockoff you might say
and you might be right
but from what i saw in the trailer it
did remind me of attack on titan but
also looking at the trailer
i can see it's got some very nice fight
scenes choreography wise and animation
wise
so maybe we do need to give it a chance
i definitely will
next we have ozakitan wants to hang out
third year student sakurai wants to
enjoy a quiet university life but
uzaki hana his boisterous well-endowed
underclassman
has other plans that's to say there are
three things to know about this show
one it's a slice of life two off by
the chick has a serious set of oppai on
her and you can't ignore it even if you
try to
and three she has a fang and if she has
a fang
she's a bang with that being said i'll
surely be watching this show for her
personality
[Music]
let's continue with monster girl doctor
in the town of lindworm where monsters
and humans coexist
dr glenn runs an exemplary medical
clinic for monster girls with his lamia
assistant sapphire
whether receiving a marriage proposal by
a centaur injured in battle
palpitating the injury of a mermaid or
securing the delicate wounds of a flesh
golem
dr glenn performs his job with grace and
confidence
but when an unsavoury character seeks to
steal a harpy egg
how will the unflappable dr glenn
respond we didn't get a new season of
monster musume
but what we did get here is a close
enough sequel i know monster girl
doctors are totally different show
but if you look at it from the fate
franchise angle then it totally makes
sense
hence we come to the [ __ ] conclusion
that monster musume monster girl doctor
and inter-species reviewers are in the
same universe
these shows answer the questions what
it's like to be around a bay monster
chick
peter grill and the philosopher's time
and like the last entry this show seems
to belong to the monster franchise as
well
peter grill is known throughout the land
as the world's strongest fighter
he has a girlfriend who he's steadily
trying to get closer with
life's pretty good for him until he
realizes that dozens of women
who want to bear strong children are all
vying for his seed
echi harem and comedy are sure to add to
the list
and finally we finished the list with a
movie fate stay night heavens feel
third part it's announced to air this
anime season so
rejoice fate fans all around the world
because your time has come
get prepared for some epic fight scenes
with top-notch animations which will
probably be
in many top 10 lists unless it gets
delayed again
we hope you enjoyed this video we tried
to make it as entertaining as we could
for you as much as possible for you to
stick around till this point so with
that being said
like and share and of course subscribe
until next time